suite en direct de la haye stéphanie
maupas notre correspondant stéphanie bon
jour
là la session qui s'est donc qui vient
de s'achever qu'en est il sorti
exactement
à l'ukraine a plaidé pendant quatre
pendant trois heures à mai au côté de
chez ace vite puisque la délégation
russe a décidé de boycotter ces
audiences de la cour internationale
alors l'ukraine a quand même défendu ses
positions demandant d'urgence à la cour
d'ordonner à la russie de retirer de
stopper son opération militaire mais le
délégué une très bien a dit s'ils ne
sont pas ici devant cette cour de
justice ils sont sur le champ de
bataille pour mener une guerre agressif
contre mon pays c'est la façon dont la
russie règle les différends le délégué
le diplomate un représentant l'ukraine a
aussi dit qu'il était ici pour défendre
un pays sous attaque d'ukraine un
évidement dénoncer les crimes contre
l'humanité ans pour les crimes de guerre
évoqué la situation humanitaire
dramatique et a dénoncé des mensonges de
la russie selon l'ukraine puisque vous
vous rappelez un quand of
fall a dit me routine avait lancé cette
opération militaire il avait justifié en
disant qu'il fallait prévenir arrêter un
génocide en cours dans le don bassin
cette région de l'est de l'ukraine qui
est aux mains des séparatistes pro
russes depuis 2014 est évidemment est
bien là la l'ukraine avait saisi la cour
internationale de justice en disant que
la russie galvaude cette convention sur
le génocide
quel galvaude le droit international un
et demandant donc dix ans qui avait
aucune base légale pour cette opération
militaire et qu'il fallait donc demandé
en urgence
ordonné en urgence à la russie de
retirer ses troupes de stopper son
opération militaire alors on en est là
les juges comme la russie ne répondra
pas d audience était prévue demain mais
elles sont annulés les juges se sont
donc retirés à 13 heures pour délibérer
et bon il devrait en dit ici que devrait
rendre une décision assez rapidement
dans des cas similaires ça a pu prendre
plusieurs plusieurs semaines voire un à
deux mois un dossier qui semble-t-il
mobilise derrière vous et stéphanie si
les juges accèdent étonnement de
l'ukraine que se passerait-il ensuite
bien évidemment la décision les
décisions de la cour c'est une cour de
l'onu cette décision sont obligatoires
mais la cour n'a aucun moyen de faire
appliquer ses décisions alors beaucoup
doutent que la russie s'est même si on
lui ordonne ce top 100 opérations
militaires mais en revanche ça pourrait
malgré tout avoir un poids sur le plan
diplomatique on sait qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de beaucoup de condamnation de
la russie beaucoup condamnation
politique de l'assemblée générale des
nations unies de plusieurs états mais ça
reste des déclarations politiques or si
la cour devait se prononcer en faveur de
l'ukraine et bien là posera un sou
judiciaire en quelque sorte un astreint
à un tiers qui ce qu'on en serait là
dessus ça pourrait donc avoir un poids
diplomatique assez important vous savez
c'est une cour qui est très respecté par
les états et par la russie elle même et
donc ça pourrait avoir du poids et
notamment ça pourrait servir de levier
lors de futures négociations
diplomatiques
merci beaucoup stéphanie maupas en
direct de l'est alors on